شكرا عثمان واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه
النافذه وهي الاخيره من مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
ثلاثه ايام طبعا متواصله مزدحمه بالملفات
ربما اهمها ملف اوكرانيا وتسليح اوكرانيا
كان هناك ايضا
لقاء مهم لقاء امريكي صيني وهو يعتبر
الاول منذ حادثه المنطاد كان بين وزير
الخرجه الامريكان توني بلينكن
وكبير مسؤولية الخارجيه الصينيه وعضو
اللجنه المركزيه للحزب الشيوعي الصيني وهو
كان ايضا لافتا حديث الامين العام
لحلف الناتو
عن ان الصين تراقب وتترصد وتراقب حسم
المعركه في اوكرانيا ربما لاتخاذ قرارات
استراتيجيه وعلينا كما قال ان نراقب سلوك
الصين كان هناك ايضا لقاء مهم في منطقه
البقان وهي بعيده طبعا عن محيط اوكرانيا
لاول مره يلتقي في ميونخ رؤساء ارمينيا
وجورجيا وايضا اذربيجان ولهذا طبعا اكيد
معنا سياسي
ويسعدنا في هذه النافذه ان نستضيف الان
رئيسه وزراء ليتوانيا السيده انجريدا اهلا
وسهلا بك
طبعا بعد هذا
المؤتمر الذي تناول بالاساس قضيه اوكرانيا
هل وانتم طبعا في كما يقال في وجه المدفع
انتم في الواجهه
امام روسيا هل
تترقبون رد فعل موسكو بعد هذا اللقاء بعد
الحديث الطويل والعريض عن موضوع زياده
تسليح اوكرانيا
نعم اريد ان اصحح طبعا هذه هي حرب روسيه
ضد اوكرانيا وفي حقيقه الامر
وهذا وضع
وهو يقول دائما هناك خط الاحمر واحد اثنان
ثلاثه وسنقوم برد فعل الاتي والتالي وما
الى ذلك اذا هذا ليس بشيء جديد
روسيا اقتربت الكثير من الجرائم جرائم
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا واستدفت البناء التحتيه
واستدفت المدنيين وهذا طبعا يجعل من حياه
المدنيين صعبه اعتقد ان
العالم بات مدركا لما يحدث وينبغي لنا ان
نبقى اقوياء ونتحلى بالصبر نحن ندعم
اوكرانيا لانه اوكرانيا تدافع عنه اراضيها
وسيادتها وروسيا تخوض حربا
استعماريه بالتالي نحن سنبقى داعمين
لاوكرانيا او قصر الزمن
تقولين يجب ان نبقى اقوياء طبعا لتوانيا
مع دول البلطيق الاخرى ليست بقوه روسيا
ليتوانيا
دول البطيخ دول يعني لنقل محدوده القدرات
والامكانيات
اقتصاديا بشريا عسكريا كيف يمكنكم مواجهه
روسيا اذا ما حدث شيء ما ننتظر يوم
الثلاثاء كلمه خطاب للرئيس بوتين ربما
للرد على مؤتمر ميونخ ننتظر جلسه طارئه
يوم الاربعاء لمجلس الدومه البرلمان
الروسي هل تتحسبون لكل ذلك
[موسيقى]
انتم يعني مع دول البلطيق الاخرى مع
استونيا يعني انتم محدودو الامكانيات امام
روسيا بقوتها العسكريه محدودون من الناحيه
البشريه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه من الناحيه
العسكريه ايضا ننتظر كلمه لبوتينيوم
الثلاثاء ننتظر جلسه طارئه لمجلس الدومه
يوم الاربعاء وربما قد يعلن عن خطوات
روسيه ما هل انتم قادرون على مواجهه اي
قرار روسي اي خطوات روسيه
هذه المره الاولى التي سيخرج بوتين على
الناس ويلقي خطابا او كلمه
الفنا هذا الامر وسمعنا هذا في السابق
في السابع كل دول البلطيق هي اعضاء في
النيتو اعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهذا يعطينا الامن والشعور بالامن
والاطمئنان
ونحن نعمل دوما على زياده امكانياتنا
الدفاعيه والناتو يقوم بنفس الشيء
عمل على تقويه الجبهه الشرقيه
مهما قال بوتين فنحن سنمضي في طريقنا
حتى لو قرر بوتين التصعيد لو انتقل من
مرحله
يسميه الروس بالعمليات العسكريه الى مرحله
الحرب وهذا يعني استخدام اسلحه اكثر
فتكاثر تطورا
يمكن ان نخمن طبعا هناك حالات كان فيها
رئيس
بوتين
يهدد باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه ورغم ان
الدول التي لا تدعم اوكرانيا رات في هذه
التصريحات غير مقبوله ولا يمكننا ان نفلت
من
خطاب لكن ما قامت به روسيا على ارضيه
اجتاحت اراضي اوكرانيا في 2014 واطلقت
ايضا عمليه غاز واسعه نطاق في العام
الماضي والان ما تقوم به روسيا هي الجرائم
حرب على الارض ولا ارى
ان هناك
توقع لما سيقوله او عقلانيه يتوقع ما
سيقوله
بوتين اعتقد انه سيقول ما قاله في السابق
وفي السابق لم يكن يسمي الامور بمسمياتها
يقول بنى عمليه خاصه لكنها حربه ضد
اوكرانيا ويندغال نسميها كما هي اذا ما
قالت روسيا بان حرب فهذه فقط حقيقه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك يا سيده جديده سيمونيتا
رئيسه وزراء ليتوانيا